[موسيقى]
تعد محميه السلاحف في راس الحد بولايه
الصور واحده من اهم المعالم السياحيه
المميزه في سلطنه عمان وتحتل مساحه 120
كيلو متر مربعا من اراضي ساحليه وعلى
امتداد الساحل الذي يبلغ طوله حوالي 40
كيلو مترا وتضم هذه المحميه اكثر من
20,000 سلحفاه لانواع مختلفه لذلك اطلقت
هيئه البيئه العمانيه برنامج ترتل
كوماندوز لحمايه ومراقبته السلاحف البحريه
لهذه الثروه الطبيعيه اللي هي السلاحف
البحريه لان من اصل سبعه انواع سلاحف
بحريه في العالم سلطنه عمان تزورها خمسه
انواع فهذا يعني يجعل سلطنه عمان من اهم
ثلاث مواقع في العالم همم للسلاحف هذا
البرنامج يسعى الى حمايه هذه السلاحف من
خلال رفع مستوى الوعي المجتمعيه
كثير سلوك الافراد تجاه هذه الكائنات من
اهداف برنامج
هي توعيه المجتمع خاصه المجتمع المحلي
باهميه السلاحف البحريه لانها كونها انها
ثروه طبيعيه تسخر فيها سلطنه عمان كذلك
همم تشجيع فئه الشباب على التطوع البيئي
همم بنظافه الشواطئ من اهداف الحمله
والشباب متطوعين يشاركوني يقوموا همم
تنظيف
الكوماندوز يهدي فوق ايضا الى تشجيعي فئه
الشباب على التطوع البيئي وذلك من خلال
مشاركه المئات من المتطوعين في البرامج
المتنوعه لحمايه السلاحف التي اصبحت مهدده
بالانقراض بسبب مخلفات البلاستيك على
الشواطئ والتلوث البيئي عبد الرحمن
العصيمي من ولايه الصور العربيه